[Music]
hi everybody I'm John graden from Cherry
I apologize for advance from my voice
I've got a little bit too passionate
talking about my company yesterday at
our booth so you're gonna have to listen
to me go in and out overtime but I got
some tea so we're good so my name is
John Maiden I'm a senior data scientist
with cherry we are a real estate data
technology company so I would like to
quickly talk about what we do before we
get into the business of knowledge class
so cherry is a commercial real estate
company we take data from multiple data
sources where they come from so they're
coming from public data sources there's
lots of great public data sources when
it comes to commercial real estate if
you love and if you live in New York
City you should be proud of your city
and there's lots of great data there
there's also some good national data
available across the country we take in
third party paid data sources we also
combine it with our customers internal
data we put it through a date
engineering pipeline we transform it and
then deliver it through a series of
api's we have a couple of our great date
engineers in the audience so if you have
questions later I'm sure they can
happily answer those but the idea is
that fundamentally we're a data company
so we're taking and we specialize in
commercial real estate data so we take
that data and we transform it and
deliver to customers I probably should
just make a quick distinction so if
you're not if you don't know the
difference commercial versus residential
residential you're buying a house
commercial you're buying a building
right you're buying multifamily or
you're buying retail they're buying
office space so this is in terms of data
in terms of information in terms of
business plans retails more like b2c and
commercial is gonna be b2b so larger
ticket items the data is gonna be a
little bit more contained a little but
not as readily available compared to
someone like silo so we take this data
and then we decide we're gonna enhance
it we're gonna take and we're gonna put
it into a knowledge graph we're gonna
take all the different data sources we
need across multiple data sets combine
them together and add and extract
information and insights off of the data
we can provide so before we get into the
details I just want to take a step back
and talk about knowledge graphs I know
this is becoming a more common topic
in the industry so first I do want to
applaud your courage in coming to
another talk about knowledge graphs so
what knowledge graphs are and I'm gonna
go through a very simple definition so
being the smart person that I am I
googled at first first answer is
Google's knowledge graph so if you're
familiar with Google's knowledge graph
it is all the data they've collected
that helps drive a lot of their products
it is defined as a knowledge brave a
knowledge base with a graph structure
say okay it's some information here I
can work with that maybe I want to go a
little bit deeper into the definition
okay you go to Wikipedia Wikipedia
starts giving you a much much more
technical definition I started seeing
once I saw ontology I actually ran the
other way
just more than I wanted to handle so
luckily I found a great article called
wTF is a knowledge graph just at my
level of information so why do you care
about a knowledge graph why not just
have all your data and databases right
that's traditionally how data stored so
the power of a knowledge graph is this
it's very easy to visualize data is
connected together via relationship
right if you think about graphs work
you've got a node you got a node you got
an edge connects them when you visualize
this in terms of data it's for example
John Maiden is a speaker John Maiden is
connected to data council he's a speaker
at New York City Year 2019 and the
future data science track now if you
were to extrapolate this and say okay
now I want to find for all the people
who spoke at data science data council
today what other conference talks have
they talked to discuss that in the past
year well if you think about the
traditional database approach well I'd
have to take this I'd have to get all
their names I'd have to take probably
another table maybe two three tables
join them together do a couple of
aggregations like the traditional
database structure does not work when
we're trying to look at how data is
connected right it's gonna be separate
across multiple tables it's gonna have
people in one table it's gonna have
companies in another all that's
perfectly and well-organized the way a
traditional database works but if you
want to actually get insights from that
it's just not as well easily work easily
developed so we like it because it just
it's natural it's easy to visualize how
data is connected and it is also that
easy to add more data right I don't have
to worry about adding something to the
people table or the
company table or the conference table I
can just add more rows in my data and
say this is a person connected to a
conference and you know the strength is
its traversable so I can easily go from
one connection to another connection to
another connection so the whole point of
a knowledge graph is that we want to
extract data from this right so we have
to first say okay I've got it if I want
to develop a knowledge graph I have to
think about what questions I'm trying to
answer right so the questions I want to
answer are related to commercial real
estate the first question that we're
answering right now and it's a very
important one for our customers is who
is the property's true owner now you
would think okay I can look this up
right if I have a phone book I can say
that you know this is the person who
lives at this address this has got to be
there you know the owner most likely if
they're not renting when it comes to
commercial real estate it gets a little
trickier it almost became a little bit
easier recently but it's not become
tricky again so for example for new for
most commercial properties each building
is owned for different reasons under a
separate LLC so I happen to work at 989
6 Avenue theoretically the owner of 989
6 Avenue is 989 670 LLC if they open to
own the building next door
it is 996 Avenue LLC very very creative
in the naming so the question would ask
is not who owns the building you really
care about is who owns 1989 6th Avenue
LLC so an interesting side note if
you've been following New York City or
New York State News recently New York
State through the tax department had
made an issuance that all buildings had
to contain the real name of the owner
so all properties had to be connected to
some person that they could use for
identifying ownership they backtracked
really quickly so the commercial real
estate industry pushed back very heavily
and they've now just said it's for
condos I think it's condos in New York
State in New York State you have to list
who the true owner is but otherwise you
can still have every separate buildings
gonna be an LLC but that also means that
you know whether that's for New York
State or not nationally you're still
gonna have the same problem and a lot of
places are not gonna have the same
amount of in-depth data than New York
State offers or New York City
specifically so if you want to do this
New York
when expand this nationally you have to
come up with some way that you can
answer this question throughout all the
different data sets you want to join
together
now once you've extrapolated so you've
said property up to lista donor up to
true owner you can now go back down and
say okay now that I know the true owner
of this building what are the buildings
that they bought what other buildings
have they bought and sold in the past
five years
if you then also look at some of the
data a lot of mortgages a lot of
properties when they're transacted will
list who the lender is I can then go
tangentially and say okay well I can
look at service providers and say which
lender has bought and sold a whole bunch
of properties in New York City over the
past year which of these properties has
seen a huge amount of defaults right I
can add additional insights that are
just beyond properties and anyone who's
connected to them it's theoretically
information I can extract and use in
this graph okay so so beyond getting
basic information out of the data the
next thing that we care about is
strategy so now that I know what they've
bought and sold the past five years I
can say well do they have a strategy in
this do they look at only small
multi-family homes they only invest in
Queens they only care about Tulsa
Oklahoma do they only ever work with
this one lender do they only ever
partner with this other company like
there's so much information of the
connections in the history this is all
time-dependent knowledge graphs so
there's a lot of information that will
change over time that you want to
capture as the data expands over as you
gather more information and then once
you start gathering a graph you can so I
think that craft structures and then you
know you get excited you know maybe
start playing around like craft avec you
know take this and start building models
if you're familiar with residential real
estate if any of you own homes the
typical approach of how much a house is
worth as I say okay well let's look at
some of your neighbors if any of your
neighbors have sold and recently around
you you take that number and you average
it right same similar houses similar
number of bathrooms symbol number
bedrooms average it that's the value of
your house buildings is a little bit
harder because buildings aren't exactly
standardized there's no Levittown of
building development so finding exact
matches are much harder and it's still a
very manual appraisal based process
if you now have all of this data
collected you know all of their you know
all the components of a building you
know how they're all connected
you know the strategies of the companies
that do the buying and selling you can
come up with more appropriate valuations
you can come up with good property comp
models there's a lot of interesting
valuation metrics that can be built off
of the data now that you've collected
into a giant knowledge graph so let's
look at the actual data so looking just
for New York City so just collecting all
the data that we have for New York City
turns out to be tens of millions of
nodes tens of millions of edges it is a
very very large graph it's not a very
connected graph right because you know
people might be in some way you'll see
some clusters here but it's also very
distributed this is me choosing one
specific property and then looking at
all first into secondary connections off
that one node now if you imagine how big
this can get as it gets larger and
larger it is not something that you can
visually identify what you want to be
able to do is to put it on to a nice
graph and then specifically query for
information that you need from it so how
do we categorize our graph so the
properties the objects that we put into
the graph are things like people names
so properties for us so definitely all
properties in New York City so all the
properties get their own type of node
anyone who is a person who's connected
to those properties also gets our own
type of nodes corporations will get
included contact information is also
something that's his own node so phone
numbers emails so if you think about
like how it could be structured it's not
like it's a property like a person
doesn't have a phone number as a
property a person is connected to a
phone number which means that as you're
building out your graph if other people
have that same phone number or other
people have that same email address you
know how they're connected right so all
of this information has equal footing in
the knowledge graph so it's the they're
the the level of information that the
attributes of each node are pretty
minimal because most information
connected to a node are nodes and
themselves
so dialing this town I'm actually taking
this back to the original node this is
what we want we'd love a knowledge graph
to look like right I should be able to
say this is my property
here are the nodes connected to it
obviously this is how it should work
specifically this is a restaurant in the
West Village luckily there are smartly
the family that owns the restaurant also
happens on the building good suggestion
if you're in the restaurant business so
they happen to also own a couple of
other restaurants so the red node is the
property the blue nodes are some of the
other corporations that they've created
to own this property as well as their
other restaurant properties and then the
orange nodes are family members that
have been associated these properties
over the past you know 30 40 years not
naming the restaurant protecting the
innocent probably a good place haven't
been there so if you want to build a
good knowledge graph we started with
what why don't why do I answer the next
part is well how do I build it I got to
think about all the different types of
data sources that go into or I can you
know steal obtain hopefully not Co
obtain cleanly pull in no one heard that
pull in all the possible potential data
sources that we can have access to to
build a really powerful knowledge graph
so traditional commercial real estate
picture two people staring out into the
distance everything looks clean nice new
it's all perfect so how do we translate
this into data so this is all potential
data we can obtain I mean specifically
for New York City but it can be
extrapolated nationally so all property
transactions are done and stored in a
database so property a went from this
party to this kind of party you have the
date you have the amount of it sold for
you have the Mortgage Lenders associated
with that if there's any involved all
this is captured by the city everybody
pays taxes so if you pay taxes all of
your property information and all of
your tax information is publicly
reported New York City gathers that you
can then find out how much New York City
assessed your taxes at what they think
your market Valley is going to be
how much you've paid how much you
haven't paid if you've got any exciting
abatements those all get pulled out if
you're listening building permits or any
attempt a permit you're requesting from
New York City you're gonna have a
contact person you can have a contact
address you can have a contact phone
number and also the city obviously is
gonna list all the properties that they
currently own within the city so if you
want to find out who are the largest
property owners Columbia is actually one
of the bigger ones NYU is actually one
of the bigger ones this is stuff that
you can quickly if you've got it all
collected you can find out that the
trustees of Columbia University owned
all this stuff I think New York Times
did a series on this a couple years ago
I think it's I said Columbia owns more I
can't remember who owns which what owns
more and more but one of them owns more
but the other one has one more valuable
property I think it's NYU because it's
obviously in mid you know downtown so
for New York City who are the major data
source providers if you think back to
ancient Mesopotamia how did writing
develop writing developed for tax
purposes all right the government had to
know how much you had so they could
determine how much you had to give them
who is the biggest data provider in New
York City because of the open Dacian
open data initiative the Department of
Finance they provide all prop a
transaction data they provide all of the
tax assessed data there's tons of
interesting data sets that they provide
because their Department of Finance
they're also really good to access if
you want to email them they're very good
about responding very quickly Department
of Building is also very important they
also contribute a good portion of their
share but you know Department of Finance
is the main driver which also means that
when you're looking at the data and this
is like a knowledge graph building
perspective the main unit of property
assessment is gonna be the tax law so
it's not going to be the unit it's not
gonna be the building I mean Department
of Buildings works with buildings but if
you're working with Department of
Finance they're thinking about tax Lots
because in the end of the day that's
what you buy and sell you're not
actually buying a unit or selling a unit
you're buying and selling a tax lot from
their perspective and that's nationally
how many many governments think about
properties is they're not really
properties they are tax Lots
now tax lots could be these land it
could be a unit it could be a building
like all these things can overlap air
rights can be a tax lot the garage space
can be a separate tax lot like anything
that can be cut into pieces and sold
rented off to someone that is a piece of
a tax lot that could be part of larger
tax ought so how do we translate the
state into a graph so specifically
taking a transaction taking a row from
pad which is the property address
directory for New York City I have a bbl
which is the borough block lot
identifier so the tax letter identifier
it is connected via pad to a specific
address so that is one connection in one
pair in my Mayan knowledge graph and
then I can look at accros which is the
automated city registry information
system I don't look this up five times
remember what a cross meant but yeah so
a CRA's is all of the property
transactions who sold and bought
whatever in New York City over many many
years you can connect these on the BBL
you now have two nodes that are
connected beach via third node now if
this was the end of the conversation
you're like oh I just take the data I've
got primary keys and just turn them all
together
I got myself a knowledge graph that
would be so easy I wish that was it's
nice it is it is not that easy and the
reason is because data is not
standardized what is data
standardization mean it means that data
is messy it is collected first of all
from many many years you can go back to
I've seen data going back to the 40s so
some of this stuff has been transcribed
into systems even today not everything
is electronically typed in it someone's
writing it down and someone has to put
it into a database so you think about
how many different ways you can write a
person's name how many ways you can
write an address when I was growing up I
lived on a street called Berkeley
according to the town I grew up in it is
spelled the er que le why my parents
demanded that it be spelled ber ke le
why and every time they address
something had always had that extra e
because that's the way they did it
the postman still figured it out he knew
how to get to our house he knew exactly
where it was even if it was a slightly a
bit off and that's what you have to do
is you got to think about with all this
data I have to worry about all the
different ways I
right people's names company names and
address names because even if I
introduce a little bit noisy little bit
typos or if I have an ultra and smelling
they all have to go to the same nodes
otherwise I'm gonna have this really
really noisy graph and I'm not gonna
have any knowledge or any insights that
I can get from it so people corporation
standardization so these are somewhat
similar but also distinct you have to be
able identify that different sources of
data will announce different man names
differently so John W Maidan has to also
be mapped to Maidan Camacho or Maidan
Camacho categorization is important so a
lot of different data sets will try to
categorize if they think it's a company
versus a person they're not always
accurate they do well on some certain
circumstances if or if not but you have
to be also add your own spin to this you
have to say personally as I'm developing
a knowledge graph when do I consider
something to be a person versus a
corporation because it's not always that
distinct good example would be the wreck
will chose trust of John Maidan in this
case I'm gonna say it's a person because
it's connected to John made in the
person now I could have John made an LLC
that's gonna succinctly be a corporation
if maybe I'll come up with a pattern
I'll say anytime I see the word you know
if I see John King anytime I see the
word King that's gonna be a person until
I hit Burger King and then I'm in
trouble
so you have to really think about your
categorization you have to really think
about how to distinguish all these and
handle all of the fact that you can have
lots of grievance this is a tricky one
right so a grant Herman is actually part
of a legal firm that represents a lot of
real estate companies around the city so
how do I make sure that all of these
different permutations of writing the
name are actually listed as a
corporation and if I want to get
distinct I can say there's specifically
a lawyer and a service provider which
distinguishes them from like a REIT
that's gonna buy and sell property and
finally common names so John Smith is
not the most common name in New York
City if you're curious you can ask me
later at the question and answer session
but yes you have to find every city will
have their own John Smith and you have
to make sure that John Smith doesn't own
you know you obviously know John Smith
doesn't own 30% of New York City
property so how do you distinguish this
John
Smith from another John Smith so when it
comes to names and corporation
standardization a lot of the stuff is
not that is not that uncommon so a lot
of good regex patterns will help clean
up you know eighty ninety percent of
what you're looking for
so if you pull in pull all your data
look at all the different common
patterns you can come up with you know
lots of red Rex patterns that you can
use to extract out if you've come up
with enough that you think are good you
can use a trick like you know some
engrams with xt booze so you train on
the patterns that you already know that
you want to take out you then apply
engrams to all the remaining patterns
and then use some type of model like xt
booster then predict other patterns that
are similar when it comes to name
disambiguation one of the tricks that I
happen to like is dumping everything
into a graph so choose your favorite
fuzzy string algorithm make those you
know anything that matches up above a
certain threshold put that into a graph
and then you'll see all the different
permutations yeah because you have to
think about like you know John W Maidan
might be similar to JW Maidan which
might be similar to Maidan comma John
dub or maiden comma J and so if you try
to do everybody compare it you might be
in trouble so if you can at least dump
this into a graph you can find
connections of you know strongly
connected components and then from there
maybe do a little bit manual editing
depending on how big the graph is but
the end of the day the most critical is
actually just good reference state I
mean I think one of the things that's
gonna come up come through this is that
knowing your data very well
understanding in this case commercial
real estate data and all the
peculiarities is critical to being able
to distinguish what makes sense for this
domain so having good reference data you
know listening of all corporations in
New York City is very important because
you can quickly hopefully filter out
what are names that you may maybe a
corporation but obviously or not versus
everything else that you've got
so this is the part where I'm gonna jump
into a little more detail this is
something where I've been spending a lot
of time in the past few months working
on which is address standardization
addresses are actually a little bit
trickier because there's a lot more
going on there's a lot of words in
addresses addresses have clearly
identified components I mean so do
people in corporations but not as many
as addresses you can have lots of
abbreviations and alternative names like
and again 989 six Avenue we could also
be 989 Avenue of the Americas and we
will still get our mail people can
misspell or tight a spell alternatively
the mail USPS still knows how to get to
you sometimes they're just obvious typos
right if I said 1989 670 in New York
City New Jersey obviously you know I met
New York that should be something that
can be quickly corrected if there is no
other if there happens to be no not in
New York City in New Jersey and then one
of the other very common ones is we're
ingesting data from multiple data
systems and so sometimes they don't
eliminate the components very well so
the one that's most common is like
Street units so St unit or Ave Unit
usually it's the post type pre for the
post type that gets reviewed with a
apartment prefix so if you know how to
accommodate common truncations that's
also important and then also addresses
are going to be coming in from different
sources so if it's coming in from New
York City may have a very clear this is
the address field you pull in that
address field if we're working with
customer data they're gonna give us a
collection of property leads so they've
got some spreadsheet that's been sitting
around for 10 years it's got you know a
hundred thousand addresses in it you
have to take that and it's gonna have
all the things that they put in there
with names company names building names
identify and strip those out as well to
get to the actual address so the general
approach that we do is all the addresses
as we get into standardization go
through three parts the parse
standardize and match parsing is one of
the harder components so this is
actually an NLP problem what you want to
do is you want to take all the different
components of an address you want to
identify and
hag them with the appropriate
identifiers so taking yet again our
address 99 670 or 417 please come and
visit we're always happy to see people
if I pass it into word tokenization for
an LT k and auntie K is gonna tell me
that I have numbers and nouns not
particularly useful what I really care
about is numbers street names directions
city state zip those are things that I
can actually match on I can actually use
to then work with going forward so what
I want to do is I want to be able to use
some type of algorithm model any type of
approach that can say obviously 989
because it's the beginning of string has
to be an address number after that six
that has to be a street name even though
it's got a number in it as well if I get
all the way to the end I've got
something at the end that's a number so
that's gonna be a zip code which is
different from an address number
occupancy identifier so we could be on
floor 17 but we could also be on floor
17 a so it's got to be something that's
dynamic that doesn't just say number is
a unit number number could also have
letters the standardized component is
once I've taken the string broken and
identified into my components I then put
it into some type of a business schema
so this is something that's actually
kind of flexible you as a company can
determine like what's the best way you
want identify addresses there are a
couple of really good standards out
there but there's no one universal
standard for how addresses should be
matched if you would like to be able to
mail something hopefully you'll match
the USPS standard but generally it's
taking your components into saying that
anytime I see FL that's gonna be a floor
if it's identified as unit identifier
you know NYC is gonna go to New York
provided identified it as a city
so I've already categorized everything
and once I've categorized that I can
quickly just give my substitutions and
parse was hard standardized is easy
match is also very hard so match can be
hard because yet again you got lots of
typos once I've gotten through Parsons
standardized all I know is that this
thing looks like an address I don't know
if this is a real address yet I just
know that by now this is something that
I can categorize is addressee type of
shape so how do you get this done well
like I said I've broken this into
components so I could say
9 you know 1 2 or 3 is the street name
I'm gonna identify I'm gonna do a sequel
joint and say find me all addresses
where 1 2 3 equals street name Main
Street equals 1 2 3 equal street number
Main Street equal Street name you know
New York is City New York estate 1 0 0 1
is zip code and then you just do a
sequel join you join it together you got
your answer
nice and straightforward you don't
always have that right no one is
ascended eyes exactly the same sometimes
you have to allow flexibility so then
you start saying okay well maybe I can
do something with a sequel joint but
then I add in some business logic right
I don't get the best exact match I get a
whole bunch of close enough matches I
join on the components I know we're
gonna be clean enough I do some
aggregations and then I choose the best
answer and I return that still good not
too much work if you want to go crazy
and I can tell you I spend a couple
weeks going crazy
you can also try some fuzzy joins so
taking your string trying to identify it
and then just matching it against all
possible combinations assuming that
people could make lots of different
small types of mistakes so instead of
you know getting the street number wrong
getting the directions wrong these are
all things that you could encode and
then try to match against your database
of addresses so getting to the technical
aspects of how we're doing this
on address standardization so parsing if
you start doing some Google searches
which is how I started everything always
important to start data science with
Google so not an endorsement of Google
they're good company though so if you
look at it a lot of people say oh I've
got these amazing reject scripts I can
identify any address that you want using
regex
if you're using regex to identify
addresses you're probably working in a
very limited domain or power to you I
hope you have a good solution we work
with slightly messier data so reg X's
doesn't help you can talk about hidden
Markov models they're a big thing that
people have used in the past our
preference is conditional random fields
because they're easier to Train and they
produce it's easier to add features and
it's been working very well I know
someone also has open sourced a neural
network approach for standardizing
Australian addresses and US addresses so
there are a couple of different options
out there that you can work with you can
train you
develop hopefully find something good
standardized like I said is usually the
easiest part because you've already
identified your components so this is
standard regex look-up tables you know
have goes Avenue nice and easy
yet again demands business knowledge so
you have to be able to determine what's
the schema from my address is also what
are my rules for how everything gets
mapped and identified and then matching
this last part so you can do sequel
joins if you have data is clean enough I
do a lot of user-defined aggregation
functions of a big spark user so a
little bit of business logic a little
bit joins a little bit of business logic
about joins go back and forth until you
get the right results and then other
fuzzy joints so that was you know for
example like locality-sensitive hashing
if you're willing to try things at scale
and think you can boil the problem space
down I kind of recommend a cascade
approach because there's a lot of
addresses like for us we've got actually
billions of addresses in our day to
address database and so if you're trying
to match all this against billions of
addresses you really only want like this
is levels of difficulty like the easy
stuff if he can match on a peer sequel
join go ahead if you can do it with a
little bit of aggregation but you're
still there good and then the really
really hard stuff like because you know
fuzzy join does take a lot of
performance that would probably be a
third approach but generally you got to
think of like easiest to hardest to get
the data so what are some of the lessons
that we've learned while doing this I am
a big fan of understanding the data you
know so building one neural network that
fits all I just can't do it I'm sure
there's more to people than I that can
do it I prefer to understand commercial
real estate data better than others so
that I can make sure that my model and
my approaches fit that very well humans
are very important in this conversation
we do have a lot of manual review it has
to be done at scale because we are
processing millions of addresses so
finding smart ways to sample the data is
also very important so you know being
smart about looking through and
determining what are your edge cases
what's working what's not and how is a
customer going to view this all right so
as you're evaluating this there's the
the idea of you know are you evaluating
your system for an internal user versus
an external user because
an internal user might have different
uses or a different interest in how its
successful versus an external user so
you might have different sets of metrics
to determine success and also with data
science you have to live with ambiguity
you're gonna get some addresses you're
never gonna get and but if you get most
of the dresses most of the time you're
doing better than most thank you and any
questions well we're looking at mainly
so obviously coverage is a big thing so
how many do we send in versus how many
get out there a couple of different
available solutions who are benchmarking
against that in the end it's gonna be
human verification so accuracy just
because we said we've matched it doesn't
mean we're actually close so you know
being smart about testing at scale
the Princeton New York this week will
here's all of the speech segments in the
city resulting master addresses are
there so appropriate understand
well so yeah so what we're doing is so
you have to start with to be able to
match everything you have to have a set
of clean addresses right to match
against so that's one the thing that
we've built out first is we pulled in
all the different you know as many
different clean address sources first
and use that to build out the addresses
to match against said answer your
question okay
well at the moment basically locality
sense of fashion so I was using spark a
little bit who was giving me some weird
issues so I tried to cook up something
by myself I'm a name if I remember I
think it's Jose Gonzalez
beside where where we will hypo and let
the potential where we going to the Toya
or the different others right well I
think part of it is because you've
already broken everything into
components like I mean this is where the
business logic has to come in have you
have to think about like is it more
likely that I'm gonna make a typo on the
street number or the street name so some
of us like you think about like or maybe
if I get the city maybe I maybe I got
the street name of the street number
right but I got the zip code wrong so
like there's different levels of what
there's a hierarchy of what a human
might get wrong and then also you can
like what I have is orders of exactness
like if I can match exactly on the
address on the the unit and then the
full address that's great if not I try
to like remove certain components and
make it less and less available to match
until you get something that I think is
I'm at least confident about
[Music]
not at the moment but it is a good point
it's something we should be thinking
about
oh yeah so specifically for owner I'm
asking its brokers so brokers want to be
able to say I found a building I think
it's beautiful I've got a client that
would love it I need a contact number
for someone in that building
right so normally if they know the
building they do you know unless you
really know it well you're not gonna
find out who it is so it's at least for
them to get an introduction so they can
then work with potentially getting about
helping their customers
[Music]